through you know father figures you're a
single mom your whole life yeah yeah
never met my pops wait i think we're of
the same um old daddy sperm club
yeah really old how old
62 when he hooked up you have me beat
she was 42 my mom wow my mom was 22. wow
wow that mix makes a little more sense
yeah so you had
older parents
i have hope for us so he passed he's
yeah the natural causes when
eight years ago nine years ago and you
never met him
how did you find out that he died google
oh my god is he somebody that was an
actor or whatever no but he
you know regular people have obituaries
online too oh i didn't know that i had
no idea why no i know what was the
um did he do you know if he ever um
wanted to be a part of your life
i don't think so my mom sent him photos
of me and a letter when i was five and i
i guess i wasn't like a fetching
five-year-old because he basically said
all i'm gonna i'm gonna keep on the path
that i've been on and stay out of this
kid's life do you think that if it had
been a suit like were you cute at five
he just didn't i was awesome yeah yeah i
was i was whereas if he was cute or not
he said he he made it seem like the dad
saw the picture and was like past that's
what i imagined yeah no not that what
happened
he was old he he had three kids and a
wife and he was taking like this victory
march into convalescence and then he
[ __ ] up and had i'm sure he probably
was a guy who had had affairs before
but he had a well-timed separation of
six hours just long enough to
to hook up with my mom and get her
pregnant wow
yeah and i you know you're 62. i
remember when someone said this to me
when i was telling them about my family
and they go well you know majority rules
i was like and he's like he had a family
he had three kids like right and then
you come out of nowhere and this woman
that he doesn't know that well like well
so you have three half biological
siblings out there yeah have you met
them no
do they know what do they know you're
out there i imagine not because like i
have sisters and there's like it's a
whole gang of them i imagine and i'm not
exactly hiding like i feel like they
would have found me
and they
yeah why don't you because you know why
don't have you tried to make the steps
you don't care but do you have siblings
not friends
yeah you've got enough people in my life
you have siblings uh yeah okay or no no
i don't have any 100 siblings oh okay
yeah which is the three that's out there
your siblings yes yeah they're much
probably much older than you they're
older they're like in their 50s yeah
yeah and
yeah my dad you know like my dad was 62
my mom was 42 they hooked up once they
went out for delhi after years later i
found out my mom and him hooked it
hooked up again that night which was new
information oh wow but yeah it was
either the first or the second time
you know this is why
fertility is such a thing huh you have a
62 year old and what they tell you you
know past your past 35 you're a
geriatric
um your geriatric
um reproducer as a woman she's 42 your
dad is 62 and they just hook up twice
and then boom they have a [ __ ] star
[Laughter]
red dawn
earner
that's amazing what a story
it doesn't really make sense
yeah but
it doesn't really make sense that i'm
here but somehow i mean my mom's 77. wow
yeah it doesn't make sense that you're
here thanks robbie because um you know
i mean the the little i know of you i
already feel like i know you a lot more
and i just can tell many things because
when you meet new people sometimes
there's just a lot of things you just
can't tell they hide a lot
and you just can't read it they could be
evil you know i mean i don't know you
know but with you
there's i just there's just certain
things that i know for a fact you know
what i mean you have a magical like a
nice guy
very funny you know open
um you you get the timing of everything
you know i mean you're in tune
because you have to be listening right
to be able to you know mean react
maybe that's the acting side
maybe yeah yeah but um you know you're
just authentically that
i think it's a combination he's
authentically a nice guy but also you
know he he's been uh acting since he was
you know i mean a kid but i'm also i'm a
big fan of the show of all you guys
thank you and i've seen you know i've
seen you before at out at our our secret
meetings
oh and i don't and but i don't approach
why because that's weird and i also
don't want to betray
the higher calling of what that is all
right so this guy's awesome can we talk
about
how how much are you willing to talk
about that oh i just wrote a book about
all of it
all right yeah yeah when you see the
secret group because people can we talk
about what that is
yeah so um